bonjour verra comment la russie at elle
commenté la ferme à vannes et à l'onu
bonjour sophy en fait aujourd'hui lors
d'une réunion du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu c'est le représentant permanent
russe auprès de l'onu va signer bgc a dû
réagir la question de la sphère navale
n'est donc pour lui il s'agit d'un jeu
déloyal orchestrée par c'est lui qui en
profitent le plus
et je vous propose donc d'écouter un
extrait de son intervention cet incident
dans son ensemble ne fait que soulever
des questions concernant le jeu déloyal
qui est en train d'être menée nous avons
entendu qu'elle déclarations ont suivi
et quelles mesures ont été évoqués des
battues ou proposé cela soulève la
question rhétorique inévitable que poser
les latins dans des situations pareilles
cui bono is fake it we prod est c'est
celui à qui cela profite qu il a fait si
vous exigez des explications présentées
les faits et nous comparons nos
informations deux facs home depot
annonce
pourquoi doit-on croire des allégations
qui ne sont pas corroborées par des
preuves
même si selon vous c'est hors de tout
doute raisonnable
le département des transports du
ministère russe de l'intérieur en charge
des vérifications préliminaires
et concernant l'hospitalisation de
nouvelles nick va demander que des
enquêteurs russes puissent assister
juste mon activité des enquêteurs
allemands avec l'opposant russe et vous
posez des questions supplémentaires
selon les dernières informations l'ex
lyonnais veulent mais a été sorti du
coma artificiel
le 7 septembre merci beaucoup v19 man
depuis moscou